>> Laura: I'M LAURA
INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LAST NIGHT'S COMMENTARY
ABOUT THE GROWING
CORRELATION BETWEEN
HIGH-POTENCY MARIJUANA USE
AND PSYCHOSIS, ESPECIALLY IN
TEENS, OH, IT SENT ALL THE
PREDICTABLE VOICES -- THEY
WENT CRAZY.
TONIGHT, MY FOLLOW-UP WILL
INCLUDE A DISCUSSION WITH
TWO OF THE BRIGHTEST MINDS
ON THE TOPIC.
BUT FIRST, SABOTAGING
AMERICA, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
THE MAN HAS TROUBLE WITH
NAMES BUT NOT THE NAMES OF
PEOPLE HE MAYBE MET ONCE OR
TWICE.
THAT WOULD BE
UNDERSTANDABLE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
NAMES OF PROMINENT POLITICAL
FIGURES INCLUDING IN HIS OWN
CABINET.
>> I WANT TO THANK THE
SECRETARY -- THE -- UM, THE
FORMER GENERAL -- I KEEP
CALLING HIM "GENERAL" BUT MY
-- MY -- UM, THE GUY WHO
RUNS THAT OUTFIT OVER THERE.
>> YOU MAY REMEMBER I GOT IN
TROUBLE WHEN WE WERE RUNNING
AGAINST THE SENATOR WHO WAS
A MORMON.
THE GOVERNOR, OK?
AND I TOOK HIM ON.
>> I WANT TO THANK THAT
FELLA DOWN UNDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PAL.
OUR MASSIVE SECURITY ADVISER
HAS BEEN IN CONTACT WITH OUR
ALLIES.
AS HAS OUR GENERAL -- I'M
SORRY.
I KEEP CALLING HIM
"GENERAL."
>> Laura: TODAY AS THE
SUPPLY OF BABY FORMULA
REACHED NEW LOWS, THE
PRESIDENT REACHED FOR MORE
NAMES.
>> NOW, YOU, I'M GOING TO
HAND IT OVER TO, UM,
SECRETARY -- SECRETARY --
MR. SECRETARY, I'M GOING TO
HAVE YOU SPEAK NOW, AND YOUR
REMARKS AND THEN YOU'RE
GOING HAND IT OVER TO, UM,
TO MY.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> Laura: NOW, GIVEN THE
PUBLIC OUTCRY OVER HOW
THEY'VE HANDLED THE BABY
FORMULA SHORTAGE, JAVIER
BECERRA WAS PROBABLY
THRILLED THAT BIDEN COULDN'T
REMEMBER HIS NAME, AGAIN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WAS A -- THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN MOVED
QUICKER?
I DON'T THINK ANYONE
ANTICIPATED THE IMPACT OF
THE SHUT DOWN OF ONE
FACILITY IN, UM, UM, AND THE
ABBOTT FACILITY.
[INDISTINCT QUESTION]
THEY DID, BUT I DIDN'T.
>> Laura: NOW, THAT'S
REASSURING.
THE ONLY SEMICOMPETENT
PERSON THEY HAD IN THE
ADMINISTRATION -- AT THIS
POINT, I HAVE TO CONCLUDE
WITH JEN PSAKI AND SHE'S
GONE -- HIS PEOPLE KEEP
MISSING THE OBVIOUS.
MAYORKAS REFUSES TO REFER TO
THE BORDER AS A CRISIS.
HE SAID THERE ARE
CHALLENGES.
GENERAL MARK MILLIE AND
LLOYD AUSTIN MISSED THE
DANGERS OF EVACUATING
THOUSANDS IN AFGHANISTAN.
TREASURY SECRETARY JANET
YELLEN MISSED THE MINOR
THINGS, THOUGH YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S
CALLED INFLATION.
>> I THINK I WAS WRONG THEN
ABOUT, UM, THE PATH THAT
INFLATION WOULD TAKE.
THERE HAVE BEEN
UNANTICIPATED AND LARGE
SHOTS TO THE ECONOMY THAT I
DIDN'T AT THE TIME DIDN'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND.
>> Laura: SO WHY, OF
COURSE, WOULD ANYONE BE
SURPRISED THAT JOE BIDEN
MISSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
KEEPING AMERICA'S MAIN BABY
FORMULA COMPANY FULLY
OPERATIONAL?
I MEAN, OF COURSE HE
WOULDN'T!
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING!
NO WONDER 57% OF AMERICANS
IN A RECENT CBS SURVEY
DESCRIBED BIDEN DISTRACTED.
51% CALL HIM INCOMPETENT.
ONLY 31% SAY HE'S EFFECTIVE.
LOOK, THE PUBLIC ISN'T
STUPID.
THEY KNOW ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN THEY SEE
IT BIDEN'S CABINET MEMBERS
SHOULDN'T HAVE MORE JOB
SECURITY THAN A COLLEGE
BASKETBALL COACH.
IF A COACH, ALL HE DOES IS
LOSE, THEN HE BLAMES OTHERS,
HE'S CANNED, RIGHT?
AND EVERYONE FROM MAYORKAS
TO MILLIE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LET GO LONG AGO.
BUT IN BIDENLAND, THE FACT
YOU'RE GETTING POOREST AND
THAT AMERICA IS GETTING
WEAKER, THAT'S JUST PART OF
THE "NECESSARY TRANSITION."
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO FILL
YOUR TANK, BUT YOU SHOULD BE
FILLED WITH PRIDE OVER ALL
THE FIRSTS THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS
DELIVERED.
THE FIRST FEMALE COAST GUARD
COMMANDANT.
>> THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE TO ENSURE THE COAST
GUARD AND ALL OF THE
BRANCHES OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT REFLECT THE FULL
STRENGTH AND DIVERSITY
INCLUDING AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF OUR LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED TO SEE MORE WOMEN AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
COMMAND AT THE COAST GUARD
AND ACROSS EVERY SERVICE IN
THE ARMED FORCES.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENED
JUST HIRING THE BEST,
WHOEVER THEY ARE?
BUT BIDEN'S PUPPETEERS DON'T
CARE ABOUT OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS OR MERITS.
BOY, DO WE REALLY THINK THAT
MAYOR PETE HAD THE
BACKGROUND TO RUN THE
DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION?
OR EX-GOVERNOR JENNIFER
GRAND HOLM WAS QUALIFIED
SOMEHOW TO RUN THE ENERGY
DEPARTMENT?
OR THE NEW PRESS SECRETARY
WAS THE MOST TALENTED
COMMUNICATOR THAT BIDEN
COULD HAVE HAD IN THAT ROLE?
NOW, SHE DOESN'T NECESSARILY
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SHE JUST READS WHAT PEOPLE
PUT IN HER BRIEFING BOOK.
>> OK, UM, SO THERE ARE TWO
GRAPHS BEHIND ME.
BASESICALLY WHAT THEY SHOW
IS MORE SUPPLIES BEING --
BASICALLY WHAT THEY SHOW IS
MORE SUPPLIES BEING SOLD ON
THE MARKET THAN COMPARED TO
A YEAR AGO.
THIS IS WITHOUT ABBOTT BEING
ON THE MARKET NOW, CLEARLY
AND WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
PROGRESS HAPPENING AS YOU
CAN SEE IN 2022 COMPARED TO
2021.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE UP HERE
AS WELL.
AND SO -- AND THAT'S DUE TO
OUR ACTIONS HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, SO OBVIOUSLY,
WE ADMIT THAT THERE'S STILL
A LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK?
MOMS CAN'T FIND FOOD FOR
THEIR BABIES.
THIS IS THIRD-WORLD STUFF
HAPPENING ALL ACROSS
AMERICA.
BUT DON'T FRET, BECAUSE IT'S
STORY TIME WITH A.J.
>> OPERATION FLY FORMULA HAS
CUT THREE TO FOUR-WEEK
TIMELINES FOR NESTLE PRODUCT
TO MOVE THE EUROPE TO
72-HOUR PERIODS.
THROUGH FDA'S ENFORCEMENT
DISCRETION, WE'LL GET
27.5 MILLION BOTTLES FROM
AUSTRALIA.
>> Laura: I'M SURE MOTHERS
ACROSS AMERICA ARE RESTING
EASY TONIGHT AFTER THAT
STORY.
NOW, THE LACK OF SERIOUSNESS
IN THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
EVEN EXTENDS NOW TO THE U.S.
MARINE CORPS.
FORGET BEING THE FIERCE
FIGHTING FORCE OVER LAND AND
SEA, THE PENTAGON WANTS YOU
TO KNOW THE MARINE'S MAIN
PRIORITY RIGHT NOW IS
CELEBRATING PRIDE MONTH.
EVEN THE BULLETS ARE RAINBOW
COLORED.
I'M SURE PRESIDENT XI IS
VERY SCARED TONIGHT.
WOKE VIRTUE SIGNALING,
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS,
IT'S ALL THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CAPABLE OF.
NOTHING THEY'VE DONE HAS
ACTUALLY HELPED THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN WHO IS REALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW.
>> MISS THE $3 GAS PRICES,
$3.50, YOU KNOW, BUT, I
DON'T KNOW WHO?
CHARGE OF THIS, BUT IT'S
PRETTY ABSURD.
>> $140!
TO FILL UP MY VAN!
THAT'S [BLEEP] CRAZY!
>> Laura: I THINK FOLKS
JUST WANT TO RETURN TO WHAT
THEY CONSIDER NORMAL, LIKE
THE NORMAL OF 2019.
WE HAD A ROARING ECONOMY,
CHEAP ENERGY AND NO NEW
WARS.
BUT NOW, THEY HAVE CHAOS AND
CRIME AND DECLINING
STANDARDS OF LIVING LED BY A
MAN WHO THE PRESS
RELENTLESSLY AND DISHONESTLY
PROMOTED AS THE GREAT
UNIFIER.
>> NORMALCY.
THAT SEEMS TO REALLY BE A
BIG PART OF THIS PITCH THAT
JOE BIDEN IS SOMEBODY WHO
WILL ALLOW THE COUNTRY TO
RETURN TO NORMALCY.
>> BIDEN BY INCLINATION SAY
COMPROMISER.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO WANTS
NORMALCY.
>> ALSO RETURN TO
FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT.
THE BIDEN TEAM IS TRYING TO
RESTORE TRUST MORE BROADLY.
>> Laura: TRUST?
THAT'S BEEN SHATTERED,
HASN'T IT, ACROSS THE BOARD?
AMERICANS WANT SOLUTIONS AND
SERIOUSNESS.
BUT BIDEN'S TEAM GIVES THEM
CELEBRITIES AND STUNTS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WELCOME TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
COME ON UP HERE, GUYS!
THIS IMPORTANT MONTH HERE IN
AMERICA.
A LOT OF OUR ASIAN-AMERICAN
FRIENDS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
REAL DISCRIMINATION.
>> HATE ONLY HIDES AND GOOD
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT AND SAY
HOW BAD IT IS SO THEN IT
GOES DOWN, SO THANK YOU.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT HOW
BAD IT IS WHEN DEMOCRATS'
ENTIRE PLAN DEPENDS ON
GETTING YOU TO LOWER YOUR
EXPECTATIONS OR BE HAPPY
WITH LESS OR LOSE PRIDE IN
YOUR HISTORY OR CHIP AWAY AT
OUR CONSTITUTION?
NOW, THAT'S BAD!
I DIDN'T REALLY THINK IT WAS
POSSIBLE FOR AN
ADMINISTRATION TO BE BOTH
INCOMPETENT AND CONNIVING,
BUT THEY SOMEHOW HAVE
MANAGED IT.
MOUTHING ALL OF THESE
FLATTUDES ABOUT DIVERSITY
AND SEXUAL IDENTITY USING
STUPID PHRASES LIKE PUTIN'S
PRICE HIKES AND ULTRA-MAGA,
IT'S ALL JUST SMOKE A